where do you see the Brand's place on in
Tech talk as it has so quickly evolved
to continue to focus on making actual
tick tocks instead of making ads they
distribute on Tick Tock yeah so our
framework on social media creative is
called sock strategic organic content
that s is everything like do you
actually know the creative strategy do
you know that green screen is working
well right now and that you don't need
influencers in every post and making
product the star is a good idea because
this industry is just hyper over the top
on the subjective nature of commercials
versus the Strategic creative practice
of social I think that's the chasm and
so directly that question Brands need to
get very serious of like knowing how to
make ads on Tick Tock Instagram Facebook
Twitter Youtube like first what can work
on a YouTube short what can work on a
tick tock and then anything to make as
many of those as possible for the lowest
cost as possible to win on as much
relevance as they possibly can